ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนทุกคน
ผู้หญิงวันนี้เรามีนักเรียนใหม่ 1 คน
ลูกมีนักเรียนคนที่ 13 แล้วหรอคะครูเอ๋
เอง
A4 คุณชื่ออะไรคะคุณคริสทีนไทยแลนด์น้อง
คุณคริสทีนไทยแลนด์อ่าว
เป็นคนไทยเหรอคะทำไมใช่คนไทยคุณคริสติน
ชอบประเทศไทยเอาเป็นคริสต์ตีน Thailand
เป็นผู้หญิงสมัยคุณคริสทีนเป็นผู้หญิง
เหมือนครูหญิงเหมือนครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมคะในค่ะ
ค่ะคุณครางเป็นเก่งชอบภาษาไทย
อ่ะค่ะ
แม่โอเคพี่เอกคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะอันนี้ล่ะ
คะเดี๋ยวพระเอกขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะสักครู่นะ
คะได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
ตัวเองก็แช่ Skin ก่อน
โอเค
วันนี้
มาไหมผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะแล้วค่ะสิ่งที่อยู่
ตรงไหนก็ได้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะคุณเห็นทั้งหมด
เลยโอเคถามผู้หญิงดีกว่าค่ะวันอะไรค่ะวัน
อังคารค่ะวันอังคาร
วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
31 ค่ะวันที่ 31 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนจะได้
ค่ะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะเดือนมีสภาคม
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะอีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะนี่ข้อศ.อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ 5 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะวัน
นี้เวลาบ่ายโมง 16 นาที
บ่ายโมง 16 นาที
ราคานิครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋มาเจอกันน่ะใส่
แล้วเราก็เจอกับนักเรียนของเราทั้งหมด
13 คน
แน่น is รอรอรอ
คนที่ 14 ใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้
รอ 14 นะคะหลอกคนที่ 14 นะแต่ถ้านักเรียน
ก็คอมเม้นท์ดิฉันค่าผมครับ
ขอบเน็ตได้ชื่ออะไรนะคะนักเรียนก็บอกนะคะ
สวัสดีครูผมชื่ออะไรดีใบเคิ้นไมเคิลอ่ะ
เรียนภาษาไทยนานกี่เดือน
นากี่เดือน
กี่ปี
นะคะค่ะภาษาไทย
ผมชอบภาษาไทยก็คอมเม้นข้างล่างก็จะเป็นคน
ที่ 14
ชายถ้า
16 ค่ะคอมเม้นท์เป็นภาษาอังกฤษได้เลย
อังกฤษได้ค่ะครูหญิงอ่านๆเข้าใจอ่ะ
ฮะโอเคค่ะครูหญิงเขตลบนะคะได้ค่ะกูเห็นลบ
วันที่ลบเวลา
นั้นลบนะคะวันนี้คู่หญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยมีรูป
หน้าเป็นรูปหมูมีรูป
แล้วก็ให้ครูหญิงดูดูดูเล็กๆหรือเปล่าครู
เอ๋ไม่ใช่อ๋อ
ผู้หญิงปรัวให้ดูเล็กๆหรอ
ไม่เล็กอันนี้ใหญ่เลยขอกูหญิงดูทั้งหมด
เลยดู
100% เก
ดีค่ะ
100 เปอร์เซ็นต์แต่ครูหญิงต้องคิดอันนี้
ครูหญิงนะคะ RO ว่าหญิงแฟชั่นอะไรคุยอิ๋ง
เดี๋ยวคุยกับแกที่มัดผมค่ะ
[เพลง]
โอ้โหนี่ผมล่ะคะหรือว่าใส่
อะไรคิดนะโอเคอ๋อโอเค
โอเคหญิงแล้วหรอหิวใหญ่นะคะใส่ค่ะ
นิผู้หญิงค่ะมีตาแว่นตา
แว่นตาคุยใส่แว่นตาให้จมูกเล็กๆค่ะอัน
ใหญ่ๆ
ครูสวยมากค่ะครูเอกครูหญิงราคา
ครูหญิงอ่ะเดี๋ยวคู๋ให้คุณครูหญิงดูรูป
ค่ะข่ายนะคะแล้วครูหญิงก็ต้องคิด
ลุคครูเอ๋มีคำถามถามครูคอ๋อเหรอคะนายครู
เอ๋มีคำถามมีสีถามถามผู้หญิงแบบผู้หญิง
ตอบง่ายๆมีต่อ
ลล์หรือ B
เย้มี 2 ข้อนายเอเนี่ยหยุ
ดกจังโลกยกนี่แล้วพี่ล่ะคะมี
ไม่ดูหมอก็ไม่ตายแต่ไม่ใช่โกรธโกรธเลยนะ
ใส่
จุกใช่ไหมคะดุเนี่ยเวลาเราพูดถึงดูดเนี่ย
อาจจะเป็นคน
เป็นสัตว์น้าอายังแมวแมวๆโป้แนวเงา
ไม่อันนี้แมวเป็นคนหรือเป็นสัตว์เป็น
สัตว์ค่ะเป็นสัตว์ใช่ไหมคะสำหรับคู่เอก
เลยถามแมวดุหรือไม่ดุแบบเนี่ยเฮ้ยได้เลย
ค่ะครูเอ๋ไปเลยดีกว่านะคะผู้หญิงชายค่ะ
อ้า
วู
ตัวอะไรคะครูเอ๋เสือเสือค่ะครูหญิงเสือ
กำลัง
แยกเขี้ยว
หือไม่คุยไม่ถามผู้หญิง
ภู่เสือกำลังทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงสุริยากำลัง
แยกเขี้ยวค่ะครูเอ๋
เขี้ยวเสือมีเขี้ยวกี่กี่กี่เที่ยวหรอ 5
4 เขี้ยวค่ะเขี้ยวเสือมันใหญ่น้องเอ๋
ใหญ่ๆอ่ะแล้วแล้วครูหญิงดูตาเสืออุ้ยทำไม
คะตาเสือโอ้ว
เสือผู้หญิงเวลาครูหญิงเห็นตาแบบเนี้ยผู้
หญิงคิดว่าเสือเนี่ยดุหรือไม่ดุ
ดุดุค่ะดุใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
เห็นแล้วก่อนไม่ตอบเลยค่ะเห็นแล้วดูตัวกะ
เสือมันดุดุเนี่ยไม่กอดกลวงทำไมอ่ะถ้ากอด
เสือ
เสือทำไมนะมันจะตอบ
มันจะหยัดครูหญิงมันจะกินครูหญิง
มั้ยมันดุๆแล้วบอกว่าเสือดุนะคะใช่ค่ะงวด
แต่กูเอชอบเสื่อนะครูเห็นเสือเหลืองแยก
เขี้ยวคู๋ก่อนจะเหลือเหรอคะครูเอ๋น่ะเห็น
เสือเขว
ชอบ
เธอเพราะว่าเสือดุจะดุ
ชอบแต่กลัวนะครับ
รู้สึกเสือร้องยังไงครับผู้หญิง
ได้ยินไหมค่ะ
โห
เหมือนไว้ 6 มันพูดได้เลยครับวันคำราม
ช่วยพูดเอ๋ไม่ใช่ๆ
คำรามกำลังเสียงดัง o  o  Fool กลัวใช่
ไหมเวลาเราได้รู้เพราะว่าเสือเนี่ยดุดุ
มากจุมากนะคะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงกูเองมี
อีกรูปนึงเสือเล็กๆๆไหมคะไม่ใช่เสื่อเล็ก
ๆค่ะครูเองผู้หญิงดูดี
เสือ
ตายลายตัวนี้ก็ลายเหมือนกันรอขอให้มีเสือ
กับตัวนี้มีลายเหมือนกันใช่ไหมกูเอ๋ไอ้
ตัวนี้ชื่ออะไรคะผู้หญิง
แนว
แมวแมวก็มีลายเสือก็มีลายเสือใน 5 เสือดุ
แมวเนี่ยคุยมีคำถามผู้หญิงค่ะ
มั้ยคะผู้หญิง
ไม่ดู
จริงหรอ
ผู้หญิงไม่กลัวแมนก็คิดมากอยู่
ทำไมแมวอยู่กับครูเอ๋แมว
เมาแมวดุครูเอ๋บ่เอ้า
แมวไม่ชอบครูเอ๋หรือเปล่า
ก็ไม่รู้
ไม่ไม่ทราบค่ะไม่รู้ไม่ทราบไม่รู้เหมือน
กันเดี๋ยว
ครูเอ๋คิดว่าแมวดุไหมคะ
กดครูเอ๋อยู่ใกล้ๆนะอยู่ๆๆเพราะว่าเวลา
ครูเอ๋เดินเดินถ้าแมวมากบางทีแมวเหมียว
เหมียวไม่ดุแต่ฟังทีก็จะฮ่าหรือว่าควรครู
เอ๋ใช่ไหมคะได้กูเอกก็เลยรู้สึกแมวดุหน้า
ตาแต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
80% ไม่ดุน้องใส่ค่ะไม่ดูแมวไม่ดูอาจจะ
20 เปอร์เซ็นดุแล้วแต่แต่เวลา
ๆนะคะ 80% คือไม่ดุนะคะไม่ดูป่าว
อ้าวโอ้โอ้โหฮะครูเอ๋มีรูปนี้มีสัตว์ 2
ตัวไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะกูเอ๋น่ะ
รู้จัก 1 ตัว
หรือรู้จักตัวไหนตัวนี้ค่ะสิงโต
ตัวนี้คนเอาก็ควายแต่ควายแอฟฟริกา
คือชื่ออะไรครูเอ๋จำไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงก็จำไม่ได้มันมีชื่ออยู่นะควายแบบ
ควายแล้วมีขนใช่มั้ยคู๋มีขนยาวๆนักเรียน
ใครรู้คอมเมนต์นะคะควายตัวนี้ชื่ออะไร
ควายอะหลั่ยพระควายไทยน่ะเขาอันเนี้ยเขา
เขาควายไทยจะแบบนี้หงอ
ยาวออกมาให้
มีแต่อันนี้ควายแอฟฟริกานะคะ
ครูเอ๋จะถามตัวไหนคะถาม 2 ตัวเลยครูหญิง
โอ๋
ฐานที่ 1 ผู้หญิงคิดว่าสิงโต
สิงโตดุไหมคะลูกข้าอยู่ใช่ไหมอยู่สิหน่อย
ฤดุมากดกมาก
สิงโตดุฮะนี่เวลาสิงโตคำรามเสียงเป็นยัง
ไงคะ
ออกเสียงดังฟังดังมาก
แต่ครูหญิงกับครูเอกก็เสียงดังนะฮะดับไม่
ได้คำรามนะคะสอนภาษาไทย
เราพูดนะคะเราพูด
อะไรอะไรอะไรไม่ได้ไม่ถามอันนี้ต้องไปถาม
มีบทชั่วโมงแล้วค่ะคำถาม
ห้ามลืม
แล้ว
ครูหญิงคิดว่า
ควายเอาฟาริกาดุกไหมคะผู้หญิงคิดนะคะดุ
ความเนาะครูเอกก็คิดว่าดุเพราะว่าควายกับ
สิงโตสู้กันช้าใช่แล้วก็ควายเนี่ยมีเขา
ด้วยอ่ะถ้าออกสีรู้สึกดุอ่ะผู้หญิงกลัว
ออกเขาเนี่ยขวิดใช่มั้ยติดโชว์นะ
โตมีเขี้ยวค่ะควายมีเขาแล้วก็ปิดแล้วก็
เตะ
เตะสิงโตนะคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าในรูปนี้นะคะดุ
ทั้ง 2 ตัวเลยค่ะควายก็ดุสิงโตก็ดุนะคะ
ใช้ค่ะพี่แต่ดูมารฮะซึ่งครูเอไม่มีจะไม่
ถูกต้องเหรอคะ
มีอันนี้ค่ะคุยลบก่อนค่ะ
อะไรครับผู้หญิงสัตว์ตัวนี้ชื่ออะไรนี้
แพนด้าอ่ะสัตว์ตัวนี้ชื่อหมีแพนด้าหมี
แพนด้า
เนี่ยคุยอิ๋งคิดว่าดุหรือไม่ดุผู้หญิงคิด
ว่าว่าไม่ดูก็ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
ผู้หญิงเห็นแล้วไม่กลัวใช่มั้ยไม่เห็นแม่
หลายสัดถึงจะเห็นทางแต่ว่าเมื่อกี้นี้ไม่
รู้อินเตอร์เน็ตครูหญิงหรืออินเตอร์เน็ต
ก็เอกครั้งไปนิดหนึ่งเป็นแล้วมาแล้วขอกู
อ่ะพูดว่าครูหญิงคิดว่าไม่ดุใช่กูเอ๋
สงสัยว่าเวลาที่กูหญิงเห็นคู่หญิงเดินการ
เดินเดินมาตื้อเดินเดิมๆ
เดินๆ
เดินก็ได้
ยืนแล้วก็เดินนักเรียน
เดินเดินผู้หญิงเดินมาแล้วทำได้ผู้หญิง
ไม่วิ่งถึงเดินพอ
ผู้หญิงแต่กูเห็นล่างเก้าอี้นะคะนี้
เก้าอี้ลากมาแล้วก็นั่งนะครับ
เวลาที่ครูหญิงเห็นหมีแพนด้าผู้หญิงอยาก
จะกอดไหมคะมากก่อนค่ะถ้ามี Panda ไม่ดู
ผู้หญิงมั้ยกลัวไม่กลัวงูเพราะว่ามีแผ่น
ได้ยิ้มใช่มั้ยเนี่ยจ้ามีแผ่นได้ยิ้มอ้า
เดี๋ยวเอกว่าไม่สวย
อ่ะอันนี้ตื๊อ
จะ
มีเป็นได้หยิบอยู่ได้เอาแล้วครูเอ๋คิดว่า
หมีแพนด้าดุไหมคะดูค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะกูเอง
นักเรียนเมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋ไม่เป็นครูทำงาน
อ่ะออฟฟิศเป็นสวนสัตว์มีสัตว์จัดจัดมากๆ
มีเสือ
มีควายแอฟฟริกามีสิงโต
มี
มิมีอันนี้ด้วยจระเข้
มีหมีแพนด้า
แล้วมีมันดุยังไงคิดหมีแพนด้าไม่ดุคุย
อยากตอบอยากกอดหมาแต่มีผู้ชายที่มาดูใช่
มั้ยดูแลหมีแพนด้าบอกห้ามกอดเพราะว่าทำไม
ถ้าหมีแพนด้าไม่ชอบ
กบเลยหรอ
ลบกูเอ
เขาเรียกอะไรนะคะเล็บเล็บเขาจะยาวไง
ผู้หญิงอยู่นะเนี่ยใช่มั้ยใช่ๆเล็บ
มีแล้วเพลงดุนิดหน่อย
แต่ถ้ามีแพนด้าเนี่ยยิ้มก็ไม่ดุไม่ดุนะคะ
ไม่ดุถ้าคนที่ตั้งแต่เล็กๆแล้ว
มีแพนด้าไม่ดุแต่ฮักคู๋เดินไปใกล้ๆมี
แพนด้าครับดุ
นิดหน่อยราคายเอาผู้หญิงชอบใช่ไหมคะอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงโอเคค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบใช่ไหมคะชอบมา
ครูเอ๋ชอบหมีแพนด้ามากๆกูเอ๋ชอบชอบเสือ
ค่ะชอบสิงโต
ชอบหมีแพนด้า
ไม่ชอบแมว
ควายแอฟริกาชอบไหมคะ
ไม่ชอบแต่มันสวยน้ำควายไทยออยล์ชอบควาย
ไทยควายแอฟฟริกาไม่ชอบนะคะค่ะอ่ะคุณเองมี
รูปอีกผู้หญิงมีรถมีค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋ยังมี
เวลา
นานกว่า 10 นาทีค่ะ
ตัวนี้ชื่ออะไร
จระเข้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะจระเข้ดุไหมคะครู
หญิง
คุณครูหญิงคิดว่าดุค่ะยิ่งครูเอ๋คิดว่า
จระเข้ดุไหมคะครูเอกคิดว่าจระเข้ดุค่ะงู
จุกมากไหมโอ้ครูเอกคิดว่าจระเข้ดุมาก
ทำไมครูเอกคิดแบบนั้นคะพี่เอกเคยเห็น
จระเข้โกรธ
ฟันฟาดหางเหรอว่ากู S
หางนะค่ะ
ขาน่ะฝันป้าง
กลัวผู้หญิงคิดว่าถ้าครูหญิงเดินอยู่แล้ว
จระเข้ฟาดมาโดนผู้หญิงน่าจะทีเคโอแน่เฮ้ย
แล้วมันก็จะมาๆแล้วกินคู่หญิงโตงั้นมัน
อยู่ค่ะคุยกับกลัวค่ะไม่กอดจระเข้แตก a
คอร์ดหมีแพนด้านะ
9 กันไม่ตอบอก
ครูเอ๋อยากรู้นักเรียนคิดว่ามีแพนด้าดุ
หรือไม่ดุ
ไส้และจระเข้น่ะคิดว่านักเรียนก็คิดว่าดุ
เนาะค่ะใส่ค่ะต่อไปต่อไปดีอีกหรอคะครูเอ๋
มีลูกฮู๋คะ
Intrend มากเลยนะคะ
xxx
อะไรคะผู้หญิงลิงค์ Link ราคาๆ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าลิงดุไหมคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าดุก
อาหาร
ผู้หญิงรู้ไหมมีนักเรียนบอกครูเอ๋ลิงไทย
ดุลิงอเมริกาไม่ดุ
นักครูเอ๋เอ๋เมื่อก่อนคุณครูหญิงคิดลิง
ไม่ดุ
แต่ครูเอ๋พาครูหญิงไปภูเขาทำเป็นภูเขานะ
คะกูเองกูเองบ้านให้หน่อยค่ะหาภูเขาได้
กับถึงบ้านแล้วภูเขาแล้วก็มีลิงมากๆแล้ว
กูหญิงเห็นลิงมากๆวันวิ่งก็มันๆแล้วมัน
ต้องกัดครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงกลัวลิงเลยค่ะนักเรียน
ลิงค์กับครูเอ๋หนึ่งครั้งนะหา
ไม่ตาย
ค่ะลูกดุนะฮะแต่ครูเอ๋เอ๋ผิด
ผิดอะไรครูเอ๋เดินเดินแล้วตัวเองยิ้ม
อ๋อลิงเห็นครูเอกยิ้มมันก็เลยกลับเหรอคะ
อ่ะหนูยิ้มลิงคิดว่าสู้กัน
ออนภาพไม่ยิ้ม
ลิ่วโอเคตัวเองไม่กัดให้ยิ้มแม่อ๋อเหมือน
แบบ
หรอคะลิ้งค์เห็นฟัน
แม่กูเองยิ้มมี fund แปลว่ากัดกันสู้กัน
ขอลิงก็เลยกัดครูเอ๋ก่อน
โอเคสายๆกูแอบผิดค่ะ
ครูเอ๋แล้วอีกรูปอะไรหรอคะมากเลยอีกลูก
เหรอคะ
อีกรูปเป็น
ฝีดาษลิง
เองเป็นมั้ยราซราคาไวรัสกว่าตรี
ไม่แน่ใจน่าจะจากลิงอ่ะเรียกว่าฝีดาษใช่
ไหมอาตี๋ดาษลิง
หญิงไวรัสสีดาจลิงดุ
หน้าจนดุกนะคะผู้หญิงไม่มีวัคซีนด้วย
ดูทำไมก็แปลว่าถ้ามาเนี่ยเราก็ไม่สว่าง
ไม่สบายก็ไปไปไปนะคะไวรัสดูข่าว 4s
ในรัฐดู
ต่อไปต่อไปก็ยังมีลูกเยอะอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
ช่างค่ะ
วิธีเนดอกไม้แล้วก็พึ่งอันนี้ก็อีกรูปคะ
อ่ะ
รัง
รังผึ้งใช่ค่ะครูหญิงคิดว่าพึ่งดุไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าดุค่ะเงี่ยแล้วเวลาดุแล้ว
มันกัดคู่หญิงเหรอคะมันไม่กัด You  can
ครูเอ๋มันอะไรนะคะมันต่อย
มันไม่ใช้อะไรคะครูเอ๋นี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เหล็กในอันนี้นะคะเลขที่ชนจะใช้ที่กรแล้ว
มันก็ต่อย
กูแต่ครูหญิงรู้ไหมถ้าผึ้งต่อยเราเจ็บ
พึ่งตาย
อุ้ยงั้นเราไม่ให้ผึ้งต่อยดีกว่าๆเราก็
อยู่ใกล้ๆรังผึ้งนะคะ
ซึ่งดูแล้วครูเอกคิดว่าพึ่งดุไหมคะตู้เอก
ก็คิดว่าพึ่งดุ
50  50
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมคิด 50  50 คะครูเอ๋จะพึ่ง
อยู่ที่นี่เราก็เอ๋เดินไกลๆซึ่งไม่มาต่อย
แต่ภัยจะจับเพิ่งก็จะต่อยห่าก็เลย 50  50
ราคาแต่ถ้าจระเข้เนี่ยจระเข้อยู่ที่นั่น
เองอยู่ที่นี่จระเข้กะกัด Voice อร่อย
ไทยโฟน
อันนี้ดุมากนะคะอ่ะอ่ะเพิ่งก็ 50  50
เนาะค่ะนี้สิคะผู้หญิงอุ้ยอันนิดอะไรคะ
ทำไมดูแล้วคล้ายคล้ายผึ้ง
อาตัวนี้เรียกว่าต่อ
ค่ะต่อเนี่ยต่อยเหมือนผึ้งใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าตอบดุไหมคะอยู่ค่ะเหงื่อ
จุกแล้วก็ต่อเนี่ยถ้าต่อยแล้วบวมใช่มั้ย
แขนก็จะภูมิม.ค.นี้วิ่งคิดว่าต่อดุมาก
กว่าเพื่อเฮ้ยเฮ้ยพึ่งเนี่ย 50  50 แต่
ต่อเนี่ยบินมาเห็นหน่อยเลยพอเราไม่อยู่
ใกล้ๆต่อต่อก็ต่อยเราถ้าใช่งั้นตอบดูนะคะ
ดุมาหญิงคนเหงาโหมีคนกิมีคนกี่คนคะคู๋ 1
2  3  4  5  6 รู้สึกว่าคนตรงนี้ดุไหมคะ
ลูกค่ะครูหญิงคิด 4 คนเนี่ยดูดูหน้าดูตา
ดู
อ่ะแล้วใครดุมากที่สุด
ครูหญิงคิดว่าหมายเลข 1 ค่ะครูเอ๋ก็จะ
หมายเลข 1 มั้ยอ่ะอาจะหมายเลข 1 มีหนวด
เหรอออกมีหนวดแล้วก็แล้วก็น่าแบบหน้า
เหมือนเสือชอบเหมือนเสือนาทีดุใช่ไหมหา
ฉันอายค่ะ
ครูเอกใครดุที่สุดคะ 4 คนนี้กูเอกก็คิด
หมายเลข 1
อิ่มจะดุกอันนี้ไม่มีนะคะเพราะว่าอันนี้
จะคอยลีวูดฟิล์มค่ะมาฟิกอะไร godfather
อยู่ใช่ไหมต้องดูน่ารัก
ต่อไปครูหญิงอันนี้ไม่ใช่สัตว์แล้วเป็นคน
เป็นคนอันนี้เป็นคุณแม่นะคะแล้วก็ลูก
แม่
ลูกทำไม่ดีคุณแม่ก็ดุพูดให้ดีแลนะครูหญิง
ไม่ดีนะไม่ได้นะผู้
หญิงอ่าจะตีแมวไม่ได้นะตัดหนวดแมวได้ไหม
ไม่ได้
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงแจกเด็กครูเอ๋
โอ้ยทำไมได้ไม่นี่มีเข้าใจไหมเป็นเด็กไม่
ดีไปตัดหนวดแมวอันนี้ไม่ได้เข้าใจไหมห้าม
ตัดหนวดแมวแล้วก็ห้ามหยิบครูเอ๋ด้วยเข้า
ใจไหมแล้วก็ห้ามกินมากๆเข้าใจไหมแล้วก็
ต้อง x ต้องไป Exercise ไม่ใช่นั่งเฉยๆ
ท่านนั่งเฉยๆนั่งนอนนั่งนอนไม่ดีเข้าใจ
ไหม
พูด
ขอโทษค่ะ for  Education
จริงๆหรอกูกูเองก็ไม่ตกมากกว่าคุณแม่หรือ
คุณแม่อีก
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่เข้าใจดูอ่ะยุ
ก็แค่ผู้หญิงเวลาคุยอิ๋งทำผิดผู้หญิงชอบ
ให้คุณแม่เนี่ยดูแบบพูดพูดดูแบบตีผู้หญิง
ชอบให้คุณแม่ดุแบบตีค่ะ
เจ็บนะไปดิเจ็บเจ็บ 1 วันโอเคหายแล้วหมอ
แล้วพูดล่ะคะพูดๆฟังแล้ว
ร้องไห้ร้องไห้ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันค่ะไม่
เอามาถ้าคุณแม่พูดผู้หญิงไม่ดีทำไมคู่
หญิงตีแมวผู้หญิงไม่ดีอันนี้ผู้หญิงร้อง
ไห้นานๆทรายผู้หญิงไม่อยากฟังค่ะตั้งแต่
คุณแม่ตีกูหญิงเก๋ไม่ร้องไห้นะคะให้คุณ
ตี้ OK มีอีกแล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะครูเอ๋ชอบให้
คุณแม่ดุกับพูด
หรือว่าดุแบบปีคะตัว a ชอบให้คุณแม่ 4
เอ้าทำไมเจ็บนะเหมือนครูหญิง
เจ็บแล้วก็จบคุณแม่ไม่พูดแล้วแม่ตีนอ่ะกู
เอกคิดแม่ตีหนึ่งสองสามสิบเจ็ดตอนถ้าแม่
ดูแบบพูดล่ะถ้าพูดเนี่ยโอ้โหเท่าไหร่ 1
ชั่วโมง
2 ชั่วโมง
ฟังนานไม่โอเคเนี่ยแต่คุณแม่ครูเอ๋
ทำไมคะเป็นยังไงไม่ดีเนี่ยคุณแม่น่ะตี
แล้วก็พูด
สองอย่างเลยครูเอ๋
เจ็บแล้วก็ขวาเตือน
ตัวเองก็ต้องค่ะค่ะ
ทักค่ะถ้าเสร็จเร็วคะทำไม
ไม่ใช่หนูไม่ได้ทำเด็กเดียว
โนนานนานๆ 4 นานตีแล้วก็เบรคพูดๆๆก็ตี
แล้วก็เขาก็พูดๆๆ
ตีตีเสร็จโอเคค่ะใช่ค่ะเนาะครูเอ๋หมดหรือ
ยังหมดแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วด้วยใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
ผู้หญิงนี้เค้าถามค่าเอาถามว่าอะไรคะถาม
นักเรียน
โอเคคู๋สอบ screen ก่อนถามนักเรียนว่า
อะไรคะถามว่าเรียนคิดว่าครูเอ๋เอ๋กับครู
หญิงอยู่ไหมขอ
ถ้าใครดุกว่านะคะดุกไหมเสร็จแล้วคำถามที่
สองครูเอ๋กับครูหญิงใครดุมากกว่า
พรคิดนะคะนักเรียนคำถามที่ 1 คือครูเอ๋
กับครูหญิงดุมั้ย
you  be ไม่ดุ
คำถามที่ 2 ใครท่านถ้าถ้าดุ
ใครดุมากกว่าครูเอ๋ดุมากกว่าหรือครูหญิง
ดุมากกว่าได้เรียนคอมเม้นบอกได้ผู้หญิงจะ
ไปดูนะคะเอกก็จะไปดูด้วยค่ะอ่า
ไม่ดูเขาหัวใจดีอันนี้ดุค่ะครูเอ๋
ใจดีผู้หญิงเสียงดังเนาะน่าจะดุนะฮะเอกกะ
เสียงนะแต่ว่าอาวีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
วันนี้ก็วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊าย
บายไม่ดุ